- You asked me to react to
this great challenge video.
Well, let's do it.
Ooh!
Damn!
Yeah. So, the guy is on a
crate minding his own business.
Then this little kid comes
around the guy pleads with him
not to do anything to the crates
and the kid just kicks it
right out from under him.
That is, that is mean.
So, the question is, is this kid liable?
And the answer is almost certainly yes.
You can hold children
liable for negligence.
You just have to use the
standard of a reasonable child.
And if you're talking
about intentional torts,
the answer is probably yes too.
I was actually preparing
for my law school class,
when I was reminded of a very famous case
called Garratt versus Dailey.
Involved an intentional tort.
In the Dailey case,
a small child takes a
chair away from an adult
before they sit down and they fall.
And the question was,
even if the kid didn't intend
for the fall to happen,
if there is a substantial
certainty that it will,
then you're still liable.
Here, this kid seems to
know exactly what he's doing
and is almost certainly guilty
of intentional tort of battery
for kicking out those crates.
Ouch!